doctor I want to know why you won't have
a vaccine
I've looked at the risk benefit analysis
like I do for all drugs that just come
out on the market so naturally as soon
as I drug any drug or vaccine comes on
the market I would wait before I
prescribe it or wait before I actually
take it myself just to see what sort of
you know side effects come out but also
there are other issues like for myself I
got covid I had some immunity and also I
had some other illnesses so I might have
some predisposing factor to be more
likely to have a side effect for example
our regular GP says you're being
irresponsible by not having a vaccine
I'd like you to reply to that please if
you would
there are many many irresponsible
behaviors but we don't criticize other
people for so for example the vascular
surgery Ward is full of people maybe who
smoke and we don't go about saying oh
you're so irresponsible for smoking or
you're on the liver transplant Ward and
you have drunk alcohol we don't not
treat people because of the decisions
that they have made
the issue is that
the
the covid crisis is picturing out I mean
it's about good news yesterday that um
the cases are going down and it looks
like you know coming towards March you
know Michael Gove said that we should
live learn to live with covid if an 85
year old patient of yours came to see
you and as a result of you not having
been vaccinated they contracted covid
from you with whatever effects that
might have
how would that make you feel
they wouldn't necessarily have got it
from me because I wouldn't necessarily
be carrying kovid you don't know what my
antibodies are like you don't know that
I'm not less likely to carry covid
it gives you some immunity if you have
your vaccinations and your booster
unless you're flying in the face of
everything else that we've been told are
you right and all the other doctors are
wrong no you are likely to be more you
are like to be safer if you have the
boosters and vaccinations that's not the
issue the issue is that even if you do
you could still transmit the virus and
if that's likely infected it not
necessarily reduce the odds you reduce
the odds
you can reduce the odds but the point is
is that people I'm worried that people
are going to lose their jobs and the NHS
is going to really suffer